[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم الاحتلال يواصل تصعده
العسكري في الضفه الغربيه قوات اسرائيليه
خاصه تقتل الثلاثه فلسطينيين في اقتحام
جنوب مدينه جنين والفصائل تتوعد وتقول ان
الاعتداءات لن توقف المقاومه في الاثناء
وصل وزير الدفاع الامريكي لا تل ابيب على
وقع احتجاجات مناهضه
هي اكبر هجوم منذ اسابيع صواريخ ومسيرات
روسيه تستهدف مناطق واسعه في اوكرانيا من
خاركيف شرقا الى الفيف غربا مرورا
بالعاصمه
رد على الهجمات في مقاطعه بريانس كالروسيه
يقول ان القصف استهدف البنيه التحتيه
ومبان سكنيه في عشر مناطق اوكرانيه
تصاعد السيجار المصريه الاثيوبي مع كشف
صور اقمار اصطناعيه تجهيزات للتعبئه
الرابعه لسد النهضه وزير الخارجيه المصريه
يقول ان على اثيوبيا التحليه بالمسؤوليه
والا فان بلاده ستدافع عن مصالحها اديس
بابا تؤكد مضيئها قدما لاستكمال بناء السد
وتدعو لحل الخلاف داخل البيت الافريقي
واتساب تتيح ميزه جديده في تطبيقها تسمح
بمغادره مجموعات الدردشه بهدوء ودون تنبيه
الجميع حيث يجري اختار مسؤول المجموعه فقط
بذلك بدلا من ظهور الاشعار على اعضاء
المجموعه باكملها
الى اللقاء